-Our first guest tonight i
a talented actress
you know from such films
as "Mama Mia" and "Mean Girls.
She currently stars in "Mank,"
which is in limited theaters
and available on Netflix now
Let's take a look.
-I need a favor,
but you're gonna have to promise
you won't laugh.
-Well, given the state of
the world, that's a tall order
-You are gonna.
I just know you are.
-I have got such
a hangover right now,
there's just a fighting
chance I won't.
-I'm being burned at the stake
and I am dying for a ciggy-poo
[ Both laugh ]
There, God's punishing you
Watch those stairs.
They're treacherous.
-Every moment of my life
is treacherous.
Any last words?
-Welcome to San Simeon.
-Please welcome back to the show
Amanda Seyfried.
Hello, Amanda. How are you
-I'm pretty --
I'm pretty good.
I've got mini horses walking
I'm sorry.
I am just so distracted
right now.
My hair and makeup team
are outside just, like,
holding my horse, my mini horse,
on a leash back and forth.
-Now, you've done a very unfai
thing to our viewers,
which is now you are talking
about something that is
so much more interesting
to look at than me.
-I'm so sorry.
I just can't believe --
Sometimes, I just can't believ
my life, and I think
I chose really well.
-Well, now, are you actually -
Where are you in your farm
that you can see mini horses
out the window?
-So, we have my house
and then we have two barns
One is a nonworking barn, whic
is where there's just two sta-
what used to be stables
where people stay,
like, two bedrooms
and a big common area.
And then the, there's hay,
a hay barn, behind us,
and then there's another bar
where the horses actually go
It's a working barn.
And, so, they're just, you know,
having fun.
-How many mini horses
do you have?
-We have two mini horses.
And then we have a pony
and a donkey
and two, like,
pretty large horses.
Normal horses?
-So you have, like,
all the sizes of horses?
-Almost all.
You would be surprised.
There are a lot more sizes
-Were the mini --
What's the order you go in
when you start buying horses
Do you start with big horses and
then you start talking about
"Oh, you know what would be fun?
We got a little --
a couple mini horses."
Like, is the mini horses
the last purchase?
-I think -- No, actually
the donkey was the last --
The last thing that we got
for Christmas one year
is the Christmas donkey.
But I think
it's just whoever, you know,
needs a new place to live,
we'll take them in, at any size.
But you do usually start wit
big horses, I think.
-Be honest, Amanda.
Did you get
the mini horses thinking
they were baby horses that wer
gonna grow into big horses
-Like the pigs? No.
No, I knew they were
going to stay small.
-This is -- I should point out
a couple things,
because I do feel like,
you know, in this the last year,
a lot of people, like, said,
"You know what?
Forget city living.
I'm moving to a farm."
But this -- You've
been farm-living for a while
-Yeah, I'm old hat now.
-Yeah.
-We've been enrolled in
the school here, too.
You know when your kids star
going to school somewhere,
they've got to
kind of stay, right?
-Yes.
And you have 30 total animals.
-No, like 23.
-Like 23?
I feel like when you say "23,"
it's 23.
-24 1/2.
-What -- And congratulations
In September,
you had your second baby.
-Yep. Yeah, thanks.
Yeah, I didn't have him
in a lobby, thank God.
-Yeah. Well, I think, even
a lobby is probably, you know,
nicer than a barn.
-You're right.
No, it's good.
I still am
mesmerized by that story.
It's so beautiful.
-It's a pretty good one.
Did you --
How old is your oldest?
-She's like over 3 1/2.
-So, what does she --
What does a 3-1/2-year-old -
Of your animals,
who is she most drawn to?
-The donkey.
-Okay.
-Everybody is in love
with the donkey.
-And the donkey -- I think
we have a photo of the donkey.
The donkey is Gus?
-That's Gus, yeah.
-I get it.
What is it about a donkey
that a child is drawn to?
-You know, I think there's
so much surface area
in his head.
There's just so much space
so much fuzzy space
to love on, maybe.
It's very hard and flat
and fuzzy,
and horses don't necessarily
have that much space.
I don't know why that's th
first thing I think of, but --
-I will be honest --
that answer was so much better
than what I expected,
that donkeys are beloved
because of their
head surface area.
Because I believe it abso-
As soon as you said it,
I realized that is true,
and this is clearly a person
who is spending a lot of tim
with many different farm animals
and taking stock of their
head surface area.
-Too much time maybe?
-You guys -- I'm assuming
when you're at 23,
it's safe to say you have
a few chickens there?
-There were like
25 very recently.
-Oh, that seems -- I don't
know -- a little harrowing
-Yeah.
-Where are the chickens?
Amanda, where are the chickens
-In heaven.
-All of them?
You didn't keep any of
the chickens around?
-What?
-You didn't keep any of
the chickens around
as just a reminder?
-No. No, there are chickens.
We still have more chickens.
-Okay, gotcha.
So just a few made their way
to the next --
-Yeah, very coincidentally
one -- two days in a row.
-Oh, you lost them to --
Was it to, like, coyotes or --
-No, no.
I think it was
an internal issue that they had.
God, it's not even funny.
I'm sorry.
I use laughter to deal wit
the pain of grief.
So don't get me wrong.
-Well, we'll leave it at that.
Internal issues.
I don't know why
it's funny either,
but I just feel like I'm
learning a lot about farming
And I feel like if I used
your words with another farmer
they might look at me sideways
-I'm not a -- No, my caretaker
the woman who
really does keep
everybody alive, like,
when we leave for months at
time, thank God she's here
She looks at me sideways
every single day.
-Yeah.
Classic "oh, when you lose
a chicken,
as I learned from my farme
friend Amanda,
it's probably internal issues.
Hey, this movie is wonderful
You were so good in this film.
-Thanks.
-Was it exciting to take o
this role of Marion Davies
who I knew from the film.
I did not know anything abou
her, the actress herself.
Like, how far into process
did you realize
what a great, juicy part
this was?
-Well, I kind of knew it was
a juicy part, you know,
before I knew I was cast,
because I had just read
the script, and I thought,
"God, what a dream role I
didn't realize I had."
And the idea of stepping
into the '30s
and playing somebody
who I didn't really know -
Most people don't seem
to know much about her.
And I got to tell you,
really hard to find
backstage interviews of he
when she's just herself.
Yeah, it was very daunting
very exciting,
definitely the
biggest challenge to date.
-And you have David Fincher,
obviously, directing it,
and, you know, his reputatio
precedes himself.
And most of your work in the
film is with Gary Oldman.
Was it -- You know,
was it an inviting set?
Was it -- Did you feel ver
taken care of
insofar as working with
somebody like that?
-Yes. He -- I didn't really have
any expectations.
I knew we were going to do
a lot of takes,
and that sounds a lot
like rehearsal for a play,
so bring it on.
He was so -- He's so supportiv
of his actors.
He's so respectful.
He knows how much
we're bringing to the table.
I mean, we're bringing his
characters alive in his movies
And he's very -- He's a
gentle hand in guiding you
through the moments and gettin
exactly what he wants without,
you know, being a brute
or anything like that.
He's just -- Yeah, I felt very
supported, very warm.
Gary and I
have a great relationship.
We've worked together before
Our rapport definitely helpe
our characters
and the connection there.
And everybody -- Like, no on
went to their trailers.
They just hung out
between takes.
-You get to play someone i
the '30s from Brooklyn.
I -- You know, again,
I don't know what counts
as a Brooklyn accent from th
'30s, but yours was --
-Me either.
-Yours seemed pitch-perfect.
Did you --
-Great.
-Did you enjoy it,
because it does strike me as
a really fun era
to play a character from.
-Oh, yeah.
Especially you know,
the real Marion Davies.
She's from Brooklyn.
She's kind of, she --
You know, the deepening of
the voice and --
Like, slightly deepening o
the voice, the slight accent
I never want to go too far i
case it distracts people
or it's bad.
And, yeah, she was so cool
She was just not like
I expected at all.
And I haven't seen that many
characters in that era, so..
-It was so much fun to watch
You know, again,
this is a film that
if you've seen "Citizen Kane,"
it's fascinating to watch a film
about the seeds
of making the film.
Of all the movies
you've been in,
what would be
the most interesting
to base a movie on
the making of about?
-I think the hijinks of th
making of "Mama Mia"
is enough to make a great,
fun movie.
"Mama Mia" has a lot of fans
and I feel like they --
A lot of people come away
from that movie feeling like
they've just been on some
wonderful vacation singing ABBA.
And, like, the truth behin
the making of it was that
we had more fun
than you had watching it.
-That would be great.
I would also watch a movie
about how awful
the making of "Mama Mia" was
and how it was just
super-depressing and
nobody liked each other.
-There's always a version.
It would be really --
That's actually
the parody version then,
'cause that would
be the parody version.
-I'd watch them both.
Hey, it's lovely to see you.
You know,
I'm a little disappointed
I only heard you
describe the mini horses.
Maybe next time, we can brin
them into the shot.
-Sorry. I even took a picture,
but it's not very good.
-That's fine.
Yeah, thanks so much
for being here.
Congrats again on the film
It's so good.
-Thanks, thanks, thanks.
Thanks for having me.